what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future okay so when it comes
to comic books great big huge crossover
events are fun I mean those are really
fun books to read but 90% of the time I
prefer really well-written stories about
one character and the secret origins
six-issue series by geoff johns oh my
god it's incredible so here's the deal
there's a couple things I want to run
over here first the first thing I want
to do it I know this might seem kind of
out of left field but I want to read
this to you guys because I feel like
this brings context to the story so in
2013 there was a really good article
written by USA Today that talked about
Superman and a paraphrase this a little
bit the article kind of threw in the
phrase said Siegel and Shuster created
the Man of Steel in the 1930s the core
narrative and Superman has been it
continues to be the values and belief
about the u.s. experience being strong
enough and good enough to address the
trouble space of the generation engage
with the character during the Great
Depression Tarzan and Flash Gordon were
popular comics because they transported
Americans elsewhere when World War Two
encroached on our shores America started
getting scared and then suddenly there
appeared and almost straight from the
flag character who's come to save us the
Big Blue Boy Scout marched with the
troops and fought Nazis in the late
1930s and into the 1940s but he was also
a reaction to industrialization to the
power of big business and was created as
a social agitator a character who fought
for the oppressed and the weak and the
1950s Superman went from anti authority
to a sort of uber cop since the post-war
era is where we saw ourselves as the
world's greatest peacekeepers and in the
Man of Steel in the 1960s 70s had
stories that touched on the
counterculture and young people not
really having a good sense of who they
were where they came from or where they
were going now the reason why I read
that to you guys is because in DC
rebirth right now we have the pre new 52
serial this origin story is kind of like
the definitive origin story of Superman
for the Subban that we're reading right
now in DC rebirth and the reason for
that is because the origin story as Jeff
jobs wrote it was designed to be hopeful
it
designed to be dark it wasn't designed
to be gritty one of the most interesting
things about this story too is that
there's not a single scene that deals
with Krypton
not one there's not one single instance
that shows the explosion of Krypton
Superman being sent away the reason for
that is because that's timeless I mean
we all know that like from 1938 when
Krypton was never mentioned and we
didn't know who Superman's father was
abital you know 1958-59 or whatever it
was where Superman's origin was revamped
and we got the name jor-el and we got
the planet Krypton and so on and so
forth all the way up until you know 500
years from now everybody will know that
Superman was a baby named kal-el that
was sent away from a dying planet that
blew up we don't need that instead what
Jeff Jones does is he opens this up
focusing on Clark Kent as a kid in his
hometown and it works out so cool
because this is all Smallville stuff and
it's it's uplifting the other half of
this is Gary Frank drew Clark Kent to
look almost exactly like Christopher
Reeve now the reason why this was done
as best as I could tell is because the
story came out in 2009 or so which is
about five years after Christopher
Reeves died the Christopher Reeves as a
lot of people look at him and say he's
the definitive Superman on the silver
screen
he'll never be another Superman as good
as Christopher Reeves granted the movies
are a little dated the special effects
are a little dated but Superman one will
stand the test of time is one of the
best movies and it really kind of
catapulted the idea of superhero movies
into popularity starting with one of the
one of the probably the most popular
superhero of all time as far as I
understand it the symbol of Superman is
more recognizable than the Christian
cross so it's kind of crazy how popular
Superman is across the world but the way
that I say this is hopeful isn't
necessarily because of the fact that
Clark has played football and
accidentally breaks his arm but it's
because of the fact that Clark Kent's
learning about his powers there's a
really cool moment here where he's
talking with Jonathan Kent we're talking
with his father and he basically says
you can't go using your powers like this
you have to be careful about what you do
what this tells us is they already know
what Superman is capable of we don't
really get the first time as powers
appeared we actually get that as kind of
a flashback and the other cool part of
this is that Pete is not like gonna you
know try to beat up Clark Kent he's
happy about it and the reason why he's
happy that is because he's got the
attention of the girls man the girls are
like
yes it is so sad this is so cool it's so
fun it's so interesting you know because
I was turning the page expected to see
like their friendship totally destroyed
you know and now Pete hates Clark kid
because he's like you're a bumbling fool
and you know I mean this is how we would
react this is how I would react I mean
if I broke my arm I was in like you know
middle school high school and all the
girls were spotting over me because you
know they felt so bad the bond was
broken I would be like yes it is very
sad that my arm is broken you should
give me more attention and my arm feel
better that's exactly what I would be
like but the other half of this is that
we also get latter lane now this is
beautifully done by Geoff Johns in terms
of how he introduces Lana Lang here
because Lana Lang has a long history and
the Superman myth though she was really
like the first person to learn the
Superman had incredible powers outside
of his parents she's really like his
most trusted friend those of us who were
reading the Superman rebirth one-shot as
part of DC rebirth that transition from
the new 52 Superman to the introduction
of the pre new 52 Superman taking his
place the whole conversation between the
pre new 52 Superman and Lana Lang in the
sense that the new 52 Lana Lane didn't
know who he was when he was talking to
her he was like you're not the Lana Lang
I know you know the ones I know is from
a different universe but she and I have
a very long history we have a very long
friendship I'm hoping we can have the
same thing but the reason why that is is
because she's been very very important
to his life a lot of writers are kind of
teased about the idea of Lana Lang and
Superman getting together but of course
Superman and Lois Lane are the one-two
punch of color book romances and so you
know they're right up here at the top I
mean they are the top coming book
romance and no one will ever toggle them
but with Lana Lang she's as really as
closest friend what Jeff Jones is doing
here is drawing on that the other cool
thing is that the introduction of his
powers are coming organically they're
coming naturally they're coming in ways
to where it's usually in a response to a
heightened emotional situation in a lot
of ways right now Clark Kent feels
guilty over the fact that his friend
Pete's
arms broken Pete's happy about it he's
get all the attention of the girls
though they're wrong with that but in
his stress in his guilt he suddenly
manifests the ability I guess his x-ray
vision to see through things now again
he doesn't know how to respond to this
he doesn't know how to react to this
he's panicking he's freaking out but
again this is where we learned that Lana
Lane knows what he's capable of and that
Clark Kent knows what he's capable of
but his understanding of a
physiology was largely rooted in the
fact that he just had extreme durability
that he was almost completely
unbreakable now the way they learned
this was by virtue of the fact that his
kids they were playing you know they
were in a field they were playing hide
and seek when suddenly a weed harvesters
started coming through now
Lanna heard it but didn't really know
where it was Clark can't realize what
was happening jumped in the way and the
shears just you know we're torn to
pieces on his back and that was when he
and Lana came to the realization of what
what to do was capable over the fact
that there was something different and
that he seemed to be completely
indestructible now at this point this is
what his heat vision starts to activate
and the way Jeff John says this is
actually pretty cute it's like you're
pretty cool um you know his first kiss
first real kiss with Lana Lang his heat
vision suddenly kicks in now Jeff jobs
have you ever happened to see this I
don't know if it was your attention I
don't know if it was your if it was what
you were going for with this but it's
pretty adorable it's pretty funny but uh
you know of course it responds to this
it kind of sets of fires because you
know one of the banners catches the
blaze and again it's his father sitting
down and coming to the realization that
Clark Kent needs to be told the truth so
this is how we learned that he didn't
know his true history all he knew was
that you know his mom was Martha Kent
his father was Jonathan Kent and he had
no idea about any of the stuff it's just
suddenly these things started happening
and he didn't really know why he was
just kind of taking it for what it was
and you're kind of rolling with the
punches but the conversation that Martha
and Jonathan have while he's in the room
is of the nature that Jonathan's like he
needs to know what's going on and Martha
feels like it'll change everything which
in some ways it will with something like
this you really can't open this box and
there's no turning back but ultimately
they decide to take him into the barn
and show him the rocket that he arrived
in and this along with the subsequent
seats are about as close as we get to
Krypton because again I like the Jeff
John said this all I could he was like
we don't need to see Krypton blowing up
you guys have no Krypton blows up
everybody knows Krypton blows up let's
just focus on the character let's focus
on how he grows on how he comes to
realize what's going on now this thing
is pretty cool
the whole idea of what happens you know
when he's learning about this rocket
ship and he's being told this you just
arrived we just found you in this rocket
ship one day on the surface it's
intriguing but because of the fact that
you know the ship itself as well as the
contents and even the Kryptonian
crystals are really kind of synced to
Kryptonian DNA that is to say to kal-el
DNA as soon as he touches it of course
we get the now-infamous holographic
image August
parents speaking directly to him and
what jor-el says is hey look you know we
sent you here from a dying world the
world was called Krypton it was
extremely advanced in terms of Science
and Technology where they're also a
whole lot of tragedies the issue with
this is that in response to getting this
message and learning that Jonathan and
Martha Kent are not his biological
parents Clark it freaks he loses it and
this what happens here is probably the
most beautiful moment in the entire
comic because he's panicking he's
literally being told your parents are
not your parents and the mine of Clark
Kent is world's crashing down everything
he knows is suddenly just being thrown
into question and he doesn't want things
to change this is cool because as kids
our parents get divorced were made to
move or something like that it seems
like the world is torn asunder for
whatever reason is true that we believe
that our parents will be together
forever the friends we make at an
elementary school be the Frizzle will
have for the rest of our lives you know
is that hopeful nature and this hopeful
nature seems like it's being torn to
shreds and it seems like all is lost but
when Clark is at his most desperate and
when he's at his most panicky and he
says I don't want things to be different
I want to be your son Jonathan steps in
and says you are my son yes those are
your biological parents but we found you
we raised you we taught you right from
wrong no matter what happens we will
always be here and that is the most
beautiful thing because at the core of
all this it's not some Kryptonian from
the other side of the universe with
powers of gods that will one day save
the planet from some unknown mystery
threatens some unguaranteed future
talking to some normal human guy this is
a father and a son and it is a
beautifully done moment by Geoff Johns
absolutely love the way this unfolds but
from here we kind of switch over to Lex
Luthor for a second now the introduction
of Lex Luthor is kind of a fly-by-night
I mean it's not the greatest thing in
the world and it's cool that Jeff Jobs
did this because Geoff Johns is really
really good at saying hey like here's a
thing here and it'll be important in
like four issues so you know it's there
but I really hope you remember it
because it'll be very important later on
Geoff Johns is super good at doing that
and it really works well for creating a
really cohesive story with threads that
kind of go out into everything that's
why I say Jeff Johnson and Hickman are
two of the best writers if not be two
best writers in the realm of color books
right now but Lex Luthor estate should
have picked it here he's really coming
from a damaged home you know he's really
coming from a
who's an alcoholic coming from a mother
who is presumably abused by her
alcoholic husband you know he's really
seems to be kind of running away from
his situation but of course he stumbles
across a chunk of kryptonite now of
course it responds to this a again we
don't really get a whole lot here
instead what we do is we pick up with
Clark hit the following day with glasses
yes the iconic glasses oh I swear I feel
like you could go anywhere and you could
just see a set of glasses just sitting
somewhere and even if it takes you a
minute or two realize there's like those
are Clark Kent's glasses it's kind of
cool you know that it kind of throws out
that way but of course like any teenager
who's forced to wear glasses he's like
look like a dork you know and again this
is just so cool the character reactions
just come out together so well and it's
so awesome
but what we're also told here is that
Jonathan and Martha had come to the
realization that when the heat vision of
Clark Kent activated while he was being
told by you know the Holograms that
Jonathan and Martha were not his
biological parents that the heat vision
didn't do anything to the crystal itself
or to the ships with a couple shots of
that fell off where they came to the
realization whether they take those
shards and turn them into lenses that
Clark Kent you know will basically have
a kind of protection for the heat vision
that comes out of his eyes should he use
it or should it activate without his
attention and so we're here one of the
cool things is we really just kind of
pick up with a continuation of this
message when Martha touches the crystal
and we just kind of learn a little bit
more about this of course we see some
images of Brainiac some images of
Darkseid really a lot of foreshadowing
here some of the things that may come to
pass later on some of the things that
have existed and Krypton already it's
really just kind of Jeff John saying hey
here's some familiar faces but you guys
might recognize but the other half of
this though is we also pick up with
Clark Kent back at school now again the
funny thing is because of the fact that
he injured Pete because of the fact that
his strength is so capable because his
durability is like hitting a brick wall
if somebody gets him too hard he's
really kind of forced in a situation
where he just can't play football with
his friends anymore so it's constantly
excuses like well I had a stomachache
because I had bad eggs you know well
I've got allergies so on so forth you
know it's supposed to rain you know and
stuff like that you know and of course
Lana Lang hears a lot of the excuses
that he's making it she's like dude you
got to come up with much better excuses
than that because those are absolutely
pathetic and so again transitioning to
this fare in Smallville that are
contending of course he comes across Lex
Luthor for the first time now this is
really Geoff Johns pulling with a lot of
the Superboy myth I was from before
crisis on Infinite Earths it what I mean
by that is where Lex Luthor was
introduced as Superman number four as
really you know Superman's first major
villain that was not like some
small-time crime boss or some small-time
criminal you know robbing a bank or
something like that and the Superboy
comics in order to bolster their
popularity
what Seagal of Shuster did is they
basically started grabbing a lot of the
main villain from Superman's comics and
basically said here's why they're
enemies and so what we learned was that
in the Superboy comics the Superboy had
absolutely screwed up the experiment of
Lex Luthor which resulted in Lex Luthor
believing that Superboy did it on
purpose
pretty the two into enemies forevermore
that was kind of a thing that really
went on for a while
going into crisis on Infinite Earths I
don't really remember if they touched on
it after the president knows but this is
really Jeff Jobs kind of gravity back to
that pre crisis of history it's saying
hey look you know here is how far back
Lex Luthor and Superman go now of course
Clark can't be exposed to green
kryptonite immediately takes it by
surprise you do it it seems to have the
same effect that it normally would that
it almost seems to kill him but of
course tumbling away getting away kind
of coincide with a tornado hitting the
fair now this is kind of a crazy set of
circumstances but what it does do is it
gives us the first instance of Superman
flying where Lex Luthor's running away
with his greed kryptonite Lana Lang is
kind of sucked up by the tornado and
Clark Kent jumps in and actually saves
her and flies out of the tornado of
course he's not able to maintain his
flight for any real measure of the tamo
the two of them just kind of wobble
through the air and then eventually land
in a lake and then of course in response
she kisses him and in following this
like he's freaking out with Jonathan
he's like if you were kid I wouldn't fly
in the daytime so people could see me
but another thing that was kind of going
on behind the scenes here is Martha had
come to the realization you know with
much saying hey look I have these cool
powers I have heat vision you know I
have x-ray vision I can fly apparently
I'm super strong you know I'm super
durable like I'm gonna help people like
I'm gonna do good things and I'm gonna
be hero and I'm gonna help people and
Martha's like you're not gonna do it
wearing those outfits which I don't know
I think it'd be kind of cool to see
Superman be a hero
like jeans and a t-shirt like we saw him
Superman true that was actually a really
cool cost of really cool outfit but what
she doesn't say hey here's the blanket
you were wrapped in as a kid and what
we're gonna do is we're going to turn
this and do a costume that you can wear
now for she's like this is ridiculous
I'm not wearing that costume it looks
terrible but of course his mom went
through all this work to make it happen
how can you say no to Mom and so
following this he basically puts on the
costume which is him wearing this a
super boy uniform for the very first
time which is a beautifully crafted
little moment here but again this is a
gorgeous story I mean this is just an
incredible story if you don't have it I
highly suggest you pick it up and read
it
it is incredible but there's actually
like five other issues or the cool thing
is that they're all basically one shots
that tell a cohesive story so it's
really interesting the way this all
comes together but if you guys are new
here to come this explain you guys enjoy
this video make sure you hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like I made up doing
this next week I think I will I think
that uh what is today I guess by the
time you guys see this it'll be
Wednesday so I think what we'll go ahead
and do is like dudes do this like every
Wednesday until it's finished which is
only like six issues it's not that long
so I guess it'll be like six weeks but
yes it's a beautifully done story but
leave a comment down below let me know
what you guys think about geoff johns
who may have secret origins and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]